make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so finally picking up with the
conclusion of Batman damned which has
been delayed like a few months people
have been screaming at me about this
people have been telling me they've been
confused with the ending of the story
and I don't blame you right I mean when
it comes to Brian Azzarello writing like
he's an amazing writer right like
there's no denying that the problem with
Brian Azzarello is sometimes what he
writes doesn't make sense to anybody but
himself and it's kind of like okay so I
had to read through this like three
times in order to make sense out of it
all so if you felt confused and baffled
at the end of the story
do not blame yourself I felt the same
way it's just the way Azzarello writes
things now having said that in the last
issue and really in the last couple
issues but really namely in the second
issue we were kind of giving this
indication and really even just hold out
write that like Batman was seemingly
possessed by The Enchantress but and and
literally was like we got the seat at
the end of the story we're like he's
choking Harley Quinn to death on the you
know the the top of the Gotham police
station with the Batman light and it's
like the shadow of the enchantress like
reflection of enchantress in the water
who's the one doing it so the indication
seemed to be that when Batman's parents
were apparently murdered that in order
to become Batman he sold his soul to
Enchantress and then went forward from
there instead we get this like crazy and
wild twist
what is up happening here his Batman
basically wakes up in a coffin buried
underground appearing to have been
buried alive now of course normally he
would just kind of die here like he
would just be left here and that would
be the end of that but he's actually
saved by the most unlikely of allies
coming in the form of like tree branches
and things like that that are ripping a
hole inside the casket and then lifting
it up to the surface he's asked you to
actually rescued by Swamp Thing now
here's the thing Swamp Thing is a really
intriguing character in DC Comics and
the reason why is because sometimes he
acts and sometimes he doesn't the
realities at Swamp Thing if I'm being
honest with you guys I really feel like
Swamp Thing has not gotten his due he
had a story yeah I had a covet run at
the beginning of the new 52
but since rebirth he just kind of popped
up here and there and in recent years
DC's kind of treated him like the
redheaded stepchild right like he's
there but they kind of turn a blind eye
to him which sort of sucks because Swamp
Thing is actually a really really
interesting character
uh in terms of the fact that he's in
charge of the green or at least part of
the green meaning he's part of like
nature itself um Swamp Thing fans I
imagine kinda have to be a little bit
pissed about the treatment he's been
getting in the last you know maybe two
or three years he appeared like a Batman
story he appear like maybe
two other stories but as far as I'm
aware he's not had his ongoing series uh
since the end of his series at the
beginning of the new 52 and so the way
he's depicted here kind of has to be a
little bit of a heartening moment for
like Swamp Thing fans because he's
lucious just like depicted is like this
giant green monster thing and that's
kind of the nature of Swamp Thing right
like despite what his motivations may be
despite his basis and how he functions
of what he does he really is by all
standards of measurement a
grotesque-looking creature but it's kind
of cool here because what he does is he
starts to talk to Batman and say look
this guy constatine is not your friend
he's not here to help you he's always
got a nefarious motives and that's true
depending on the way that the
Constantine is written sometimes he
really does try to do good things but
more often than not he's kind of
nefarious right I mean for those you
guys who read injustice that's a really
good example it is an alternate reality
story but for those of you guys who read
injustice when it came to year 3 or year
4 I think it was I think it was year 3
he basically like tricked the entirety
of the superhero and super villain
community to say the little girl that
was in his charge and that was it like
that was the only purpose he really
served what it was was to basically like
trick everyone to use everybody to his
own ends it was cool it was a good
chance to see a lot of that that
mystical and dark side of magic when it
came to DC but in in this instance Swamp
Thing really kind of seems we play more
of a word of caution right he's not a
tried and true ally insofar as like he's
fighting on the side of Batman it's
really more of like hey a few words of
warning do not trust this guy this guy
is not your friend now of course in the
middle of all this you end up having one
of the statues which is possessed by by
The Enchantress who comes running up on
Constantine and then of course you know
is basically stopped by the combined
efforts of Constantine Batman and and
Swamp Thing and that's really it like
these busy you'll wrap up pretty fast
with this regard in terms of enchantress
kind of being chased off but she keeps
saying things like be mine you know like
like you know a fate was written and all
I kind of good stuff
it's very cloak-and-dagger but it all
really seems to continue to hint to the
idea that Batman sold his soul to her
and that's why he's in his current state
it's kind of cool to see how this whole
little this whole little scenario
unfolds something else that I want to
draw your attention to it's something
that I didn't notice the first time that
I went around and read this
it wasn't until actually Mariah pointed
it out the Batman skin is degrading like
he's literally falling apart like his
his skin is basically you know kind of
breaking down and and he's essentially
eroding or rotting that'll become
important later on but again because of
the fact that Swamp Thing warns Batman
because he says hey look this guy is not
your friends Constantine is basically
leading you on a wild goose chase he's
not really giving
any definitive answers here if you sit
down and you look at what's going on you
need to go get some answers and that's
exactly when Batman says enough of all
this hoopla enough of this nonsense like
we need some answers like we need to go
to a place where we can get some answers
and so what they end up doing is they
end up going to the layer of Zatanna now
this is a cool thing because when it
comes to them the Magical side of DC
there are characters that always pop up
right so like dead man Boston brand is
Itano now he's usually the most popular
ones the ones that have played like
major roles and stories in like the last
10 to 15 years of Infinite Crisis Final
Crisis blackest night different things
like that they're kind of like that the
character is that everybody who knows
about the magical dark side thinks up
first right so like when you think of
like DC Comics you think of like Batman
Superman Wonder Woman that kind of thing
they're really almost the equivalent of
that not so much in terms of power but
in terms of notoriety among like the
readership in DC Comics and so showing
up to the realm of Zatanna again we
really kind of give this intro which is
par for the course when it comes to her
character being introduced into any one
particular story that can be read as
standalone meaning you don't have to
read anything else it's designed to kind
of be a refresher about her character
she works on magic she says her words
backwards in order to cast spells and
then she's really all just about
tantalizing people and and being more of
like a sultry you're having a sultry
appearance but in the middle of all that
you have like Boston brand who shows up
and starts some crap for a little while
like he possesses Constantine and then
like that's basically it they just kind
of you know and ends up being you know
kind of sent away by katana but it's
kind of a cool thing because when the
questions when really the the scenario
comes in where it's like it's time for
Batman to get some questions and he sits
down with cetana
and then the idea is you need to speak
with the only person who can really give
you a definitive answer to what's going
on with your life right now when this
happens we end up getting the child
version of Bruce Wayne and and my first
thought was what like like okay either
this is not Batman or Batman is dead
like that's the only way to really
figure it out right and there's the only
way for it to make sense the like it's
the child version of Bruce and it's a
cool little moment because it's
basically the statement like be brave
and then like Batman get some answers
and then he leaves and we never find out
right off the bat what those answers are
at least it wasn't seem to be that way
but then he wakes up with with
Constantine in Crime Alley that night
his parents were shot and that's what we
end up finding out Batman's been dead
this entire time that Thomas and Martha
Wayne were shot but so was Bruce and
that's why he saw that little child
version of himself appearing as a ghost
because Batman's dead and basically
everything
that's been going on here is his own
version of health the Gotham City is
held like Batman's living through this
hellish landscape now the funny thing
about this is that we'll see something
here in a minute that will kind of seem
to change that to a degree but like when
the questions asked by Constantine what
are you gonna do now that man says I'm
gonna go to the place that I should have
gone the entire time and so what he has
up doing is he has up traveling to the
morgue only to run into the homeless man
that he found at the beginning of the
story back in issue number one and this
homeless man as we know is the specter
now of course for those of you guys who
were unfamiliar with this the spectre is
basically the judgment of God rights
like those individuals who have
committed crimes or committed acts that
are deemed against the will of God or at
least you know heinous enough this
Specter will show up and whisk you away
and the spectre is hugely powerful it's
one of those things because you know
with the specter being the spirit of
God's judgment it doesn't necessarily
make him all-powerful right like this
Specter can be defeated the specter is a
spirit and by virtue of being a spirit
is an actual entity that exists out
there and can be taken over and in the
event like Batman basically starts
talking to to the spectre and the
spectre says you know what it was that
you did I am here to judge you like I'm
here for the thing for the for the act
that you committed and in this hellish
landscape in this afterlife landscape
that Batman's been experiencing odd that
in his fight with the Joker that took
place just before this story started
right so like the basis behind the story
for the Joker had actually mortally
wounded Batman in Batman was going to
save him but where the Joker was hanging
on for dear life
Batman's concern was what would the
Joker do when I'm gone with me being
mortally injured basically what's the
Joker gonna do because I'm gonna die
like right I mean you know when Batman
did not know that he was basically
already dead and in this afterlife he
believed the Joker who had essentially
mortally wounded him and if he did and
Batman died what was the Joker gonna do
with Gotham City and so instead of
worrying about that Batman let the Joker
die he let him fall to his death and so
it's one of these things where like you
never really see Batman act this way now
a lot of like traditional Batman fans
are gonna kind of be pissed about it
like that man never kills anyone I mean
he does they're just kind of sweeping
out under the rug and kind of ignoring
it but like Batman's killed people
before and so because of that you know
it's one of these things where the the
spectre is judging Batman because Batman
willingly allowed someone to die and
that's the basis behind this if the
Joker was truly incorrigible incapable
of becoming a better person then the
acts of Batman would be justified right
because there'd be no conceivable way
for Joker to go back to being a normal
human being or the very least to like
rip hint for his actions and to walk
away but as we know from the bat
Joker mythology the the history between
the two of them did Joker does what he
does because he loves the cat and mouse
game with Batman but if Batman were to
die the Joker would seemingly have no
purpose we can actually be left to
believe the Joker would just end his own
life in that instance because he
wouldn't have we wouldn't see himself as
having a purpose or a motivation anymore
because he lives to basically be in the
conflict with Batman as that kind of
seems to be the basis behind what the
spectre is doing is by virtue of you
dying it would have allowed the Joker to
kind of move past being a villain the
way he's always been and either retreat
into himself and just not bother anybody
anymore or in his own life to you know
in hopes that he could change you around
in the afterlife but you never granted
that possibility you took away his
ability to make that choice you are
guilty of murder and the result is that
he basically condemns Batman but it's a
funny thing because Batman sits down and
says yes but like basically I'm already
dead you know as you judge others I will
judge you
and so Batman's last statement is I wish
the Joker was still alive and then
basically is resigned into the morgue
essentially like back into his spirit
you know kinda going back to where it
was that you that he was at before it
right so like his spirit is basically
left now now we don't know if his spirit
went to actual hell if he was in actual
hell the whole time we don't really know
we're just kind of left to believe that
is some kind of hellish purgatory like
landscape and it's really kind of left
on an ambiguous no but then you end up
having this this sort of equivalent to a
post-credits scene in the comic where
Joker's body falling from you falling
from the bridge and then dying doesn't
happen instead he emerges from the water
is alive as he ever was and then you
know you get the The Killing Joke kind
of laughter at the you know The Killing
Joke appearance at the end of it kind of
the iconic Joker scene and then we're
left to believe he's gonna go on and
continue being the Joker and Gotham's
gonna be worse because of it so again
like it's an amazing ending to a story
like it's so good like I love Brian
Azzarello writing so it's really really
awesome to see you like this whole thing
unfold and and this run I'll turn out
the way that it did but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain and make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
rock for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]